so
remember reverend tracy g
the the new super villain that we found
online
um i want to show you something i have a
few videos of hers but i want to show
you the origins of this because
at one point she was a normal person
she was i don't know what made her turn
i have no idea
but at one point she was a normal person
so this video is from
almost 11 years ago okay 10 and a half
years ago
this is on her same youtube channel the
same youtube channel that we that we got
her crazy [ __ ] uh
serial killer rants that she does
so check it out this is her this used to
be normal this is her
it's the same person
hi michael this is tracy aka model
i am sending you this video response
to the whole gossip
bam uh the section of your
um start your own adventure so you could
see
seems like a pretty normal youtube video
yes i number one i do think jimmy can
make a comeback because she's being
honest about what she's
doing maybe she won't be like um
a children's idol kind of like hillary
duff
and britney spears but eventually once
she works through it and comes
and comes clean with everything she can
she can definitely make a comeback i
have high hopes for demi lovato
and um i'm i really am i would be remiss
to comment on your second question
however leon rhymes i love her loved her
since she was 12 years old
she is so awesome but her personal life
if she doesn't want if if she doesn't
want the backlash she shouldn't look how
normal she is
and you know not only should we have
same-sex marriages
on dancing with the stars michael but we
should have them i've been watching
these things very closely we should have
them
on jewelry commercials i am so tired of
just seeing
a men and women falling in love i'm not
big on romance anyway
romance is just it's a waste of time and
money
better to work on the relationship than
trying to schmooze them
anyhow but i still think it would be
really nice to see same-sex
couples on all of these um
jewelry commercials i would name a
couple of places but i'm sure i'd
probably
they'd probably try to sue me or youtube
would delete my video
and mostly last but not least i have
been commenting
on the i want an ipad because for a long
time and i've
always given you thumbs up when i've had
a chance to watch you and i
always comment or i send you a video
response
and my favorite comment that i put in so
far is
i want an ipad because i'd like to hear
the chatter at kelso high school
now obviously lefty
with awoke [ __ ] but outside of that
seem normal okay this is the video that
i'm about to play
and this is platypus thing i've played
some of his videos before
a lot of he's clipped some shady stuff
and some e frog stuff
but he did he did this video two years
ago and i never
i never saw it okay i've never seen this
until today so that's tracy uh
reverend tracy g
this is um
like a super cut of her
beginning in 2011 through 2017.
she ready check it out okay so like um i
totally my biggest biggest pet peeve of
all
on the road is when people like they
like pass you really fast just to
screech to a halt at the oncoming stop
sign
okay now if it's a red light you know
sometimes it's green when they try to
patch you and then it turns red
but when it's an actual stop sign and
you're going say
25 in the 25 zone and they pass you
going like
50 and then they crunch in front of you
and screech to a halt which makes you
slam on your brakes
which is really ridiculous and dangerous
but then there's the other one too like
when i have my tunes up because i listen
to all music and when i have the tunes
up i have these you know i rock out i
dance
i raise a roof you know because i'm real
hip and i'm into what's in today
about 15 years ago and so you know i'm
rocking
all right and people come by and they
look at me like i'm all crazy
they point like what at least they're
laughing
if they're laughing at me at least
they're laughing and
then i think oh well they're just
jealous because i'm happy and i got a
compliment the other day believe it or
not
i wish i could be as happy as you are
well that's a choice sweetheart
turn around and just be happy it's a
choice
why live in sadness i like to rock in my
car why do i like to rock in my car
because i'm a happy person
anyhow peace love happiness
was she doing a bit maybe
hi i know my other video was kind of
wonky that's because my webcam is dying
and it's kind of a cheap little thing
anyway
but what i wanted to say chris is that
you just you have to love a liar
you have to forgive them cut them out of
your life
and let them go it's the only way wow
this video really shows the
deterioration of her mental
mental health like it's it's it's
actually like i'm gonna
forgive let go i'm gonna skip ahead a
little
because my mom sat for hours entering
her comments to win for me
i love my mom and i love michael buckley
he makes me laugh he makes me cry
you should open a youtube account and
subscribe to him yay
okay go down a little bit more number
one
i think i'm really scared because i made
a commitment to myself to at least go to
a comedy club this
by the end of this month and do a
routine which is totally freaking me out
she's going to do stand up and i was
comfortable doing it but it's been so
long that now i'm so afraid
to do it that um i'm constantly
trying to talk myself out
i don't know that's her real hair that
seems fake
she aged like 100 years in 10 years
after my shower i got to look in at my
hair in the mirror
and although this is a really crappy
um old-time microsoft video
um photoshop
from this is pretty much my hair
so um
i grew up around
oh so many different people
but the running thing amongst the white
the predominantly white getting crazier
families
that i grew up were getting crazier
was racism towards anybody especially
blacks and mexicans
i say this not to refer to myself
as any kind of
racist but in many of these homes
i was told i had
i did not look let me tell you something
i did not see that one coming
just excuse me just give me one minute
please
[Music]
hahahahahahahahahahaha
[Music]
ugh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
look i didn't know that was coming just
so you guys know i didn't go through a
[ __ ]
hour of this video it's an hour long
video
all right
[Laughter]
look we'll continue the video i'm very
sorry
that that actually broke me that that
that that got me man that got me
legitimately got me i did not
see that coming that came out of nowhere
in many of these homes i was told i had
hair
i know it doesn't seem like much but in
the 1970s in dp oklahoma there was still
white bathrooms this was like 1972
now 3 4 1975
1976 part of 1977.
there was still white drinking fountains
and black drinking them
there was a white cemetery in black
cemetery
and i was just young i was born in
1970 and i remember thinking that that
was wrong
and i didn't understand and
i preferred the dirty drinking fountain
over the clean one because i could
touch it and not have people
tell me i was gross but to be screamed
at
and to be smacked for using it and that
i should use the white girls
and then to get smacked for
making the white porcelain dirty
confused me and all i knew is i was
getting hit
told i had hair go ahead and use it
stop could you [ __ ] relax with that
i was only worth that of a
whoa stop it stop it
i gave you one you took three hurtful
and hateful
and it is
and it was just as hurtful and hateful
at four and six and seven
to a little white girl because not only
was i
um nappy-headed
stop four that's four you gotta stop
lady you gotta stop
and when i show up at school i was told
i smelled like [ __ ]
and they would not be allowed and they
wouldn't let me sit with the kids that
smelled pretty
on the farm i was happy sort of
that's another story
we would get up at 4 4 30 in the morning
which i still do
to this day um
to take care of the animals and i loved
it and i
felt wonderful and it was joyful
and then to go to school and be told
that what i did was dirty and filthy
and yet they were eating the food that
they were putting on their plates
it was my hand she's crazy this woman is
[Music]
nuts
i didn't understand
for the family that was supposed to be
taking care of me
in my mother's absence
they treat me like less than a human as
blacks were
in the 1970s oh i'm sorry lady
i gotta ask a question are you implying
that blacks
were less than human because that's what
you said i think what you meant to say
was
black people were treated as less than
human
how did she go from that demi lovato
video to
here and we're only midway through the
transition
and then to have the people that i was
feeding
treat me like [ __ ] i just didn't get it
i couldn't understand why don't i fit in
my natural mother she was so good
um she fought against racism in her own
family the matriarch of her family
in fact my favorite quote from this
woman is
um i'm not racist
but they only choose
the black people and the mexicans to
have an opportunity
to win the car on the price is right
so so
we went from they called her
n-word hair they treated her badly when
she lived on a farm
and they only let mexicans and black
people win the car on price is right
am i correct
that's not racist at all no
my second favorite from her was
is because she's still living is
what they do is not what they do is
reverse racism
no my dear i've told you repetitively
racism is racism one race against
another
but she's in her 80s what do you undo
right
the thing about the prices right i told
her you know they had such a low
audience towards the end of bob barker's
reign on the show
that they were pulling people in from
the streets and you know who lives in
that part of hollywood
i'm assuming you're gonna say it but is
the way you could say it without a hard
r at least
have you ever walked down that part of
the street i actually
have again is there a way you could say
this
nicely i've been there to go on the show
and it's dirty and filthy and you know
who lives
poor blacks and poor mexicans and they
pull them off of the street
for their free tickets so they'll fill
the seats and that's how you get on the
show
close one that was a close one we're
right we're right
racism or no i say it's a matter of
proximity
so drenched in racism
totally happy hair oh come on
the [ __ ] man come on
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you
it's youtube lady
[ __ ] five
totally gonna drink from the black
drinking fountain because it's dirty
and then i dirty the white one and be
smacked until go ahead and go drink from
the black one
i don't understand but my natural mother
was you were born in the 70s there was
no black water fountains and white water
fountains you [ __ ] pathological liar
so good that not only was she rebellious
against her family but she was so
rebellious that she entrenched me
in other cultures specifically
black culture and
some native american specifically
the navajo indians in new mexico
so
my my natural mother was
she so much didn't want to be part of
the racism
that she pushed herself to go
outside of it and go
ha ha look what i'm doing
[ __ ] you you know what i'm gonna start
telling my truth
and i'm gonna start looking at the truth
of it and i'm gonna start telling the
world and the universe that's doing
things against
fellow men this is when it started this
is the moment
we we got the moment we we found the
moment
she went from making these fun videos
about stand-up comedy and how
demi lovato and stuff like that this is
the moment it's
right here
this is where it happened
this is where
it happened